tous
bonsoir le deuil et les questions après
la tragédie de fourie a ni le deuil avec
aujourd'hui la mort de deux autres
victimes et les premières cérémonies
d'inhumation les questions toujours plus
insistantes toujours plus précises pour
savoir comment le drame a pu avoir lieu
et qui est responsable
ce soit encore nous sommes en mesure de
vous présenter un document déterminant
pour l'anc est un document amateur
tournée par un homme qui souhaite garder
l'anonymat
il était sur la tribune au moment de la
chute la caméra ne fait jamais arrêter
de filmer rémy goody cheli début nord de
furiani mardi soir
regardez bien ce document dans quelques
secondes les gradins vont littéralement
se dérober sous les pieds du caméraman
amateur qui tourne ces images
cinq à huit secondes de chute tout au
plus et l'horreur la tribune s'est coupé
en deux la tribune qui s'est détaché
c'est alors un vitesse très réduite puis
tout d'un coup elle s'est effondrée dans
un fracas épouvantable
on aurait dit qu'elle avait été scié
comme comme d'un coup de couteau et je
marquais quand la partie qui n'est pas
tombé et l'autre partie c'était pas
relié à vick avait un couloir elle était
liée que vers le haut et ça m'inquiète
un peu pour ça aussi que je ne suis pas
monté sur cette débile de témoignages
qui attestent de la différence de
structure entre les deux parties de la
tribune celle qui s'était fondé
s'affrontaient plus un échafaudage mal
arrimés est sans doute monter trop
rapidement
tous ceux qui ont vécu le drame
attendent maintenant que les enquêteurs
déterminent clairement comment on a pu
en arriver là mais vraies ou fausses
autorisations bonne ou mauvaise
construction
le pire a bien eu lieu c'est facile à
faire si jamais personne pourra l'ouvrir
et bien dans la mémoire du club c'est
fini je pense que le biberon
la corse je vous le dise est en deuil
les premières victimes ont été inhumées
ce matin à bastia et une chapelle
ardente a été dressée
des milliers de personnes sont venues
rendre hommage aux victimes et aux
familles touchées par ce drame
je vous rappelle le dernier bilan douze
morts et 450 blessés
et puis dernières informations sur ce
dossier la finale de la coupe de france
a finalement été transformé en match de
solidarité
il sera joué mardi prochain tout de
suite les autres faits marquants de
l'actualité le journal du jour jean paul
girouard
george bush à los angeles à quatre
semaines des primaires en californie le
président américain a pu constater les
dégâts des récentes émeutes
il s'est dit prête à relever le défi de
la pauvreté et de la reconstruction des
quartiers détruits
environ 400 coréen et hispaniques ont
manifesté devant son hôtel pour
protester contre la passivité de la
police pendant la révolte tente eu en
algérie les contrôles policiers ont été
sensiblement renforcé à la veille de la
prière du vendredi
hier trois intégristes dont deux
militaires ont été condamnés à mort par
le tribunal militaire d'alger depuis le
début de la semaine 16 militants
intégristes ont été condamnés à la peine
capitale
par ailleurs un nouvel attentat à la
bombe a fait trois morts hier à
l'université de constantine
peut-être le déblocage de la grève des
fonctionnaires en allemagne l'un des
deux principaux syndicats du service
public a recommandé à ses membres
d'accepter la nouvelle offre du collège
des employeurs d'une hausse des salaires
de 5 4%
cet après midi le chancelier kohl avait
appelé les partenaires sociaux à la
modération
la fen explose la fédération de
l'éducation nationale a exclu le
syndicat national de l'enseignement du
second degré le snes et celui de
l'éducation physique le snep pour cause
d'opposition systématique à la ligne de
la fédération le snes et le snep ont
déposé un recours juridique devant le
tribunal de grande instance de paris le
19 20 et donc écourté ce soir mais pour
faire place à un grand événement
l'ouverture du 45ème festival de cannes
place donc à une émission spéciale de la
3 présentée en direct par paul amar qui
est accompagné du président du festival
gérard depardieu de catherine deneuve de
philippe noiret de charlotte rampling et
de sophie marceau
place donc au cinéma